We bring down the bank... this is like
bringing down the your mountaineering
partner on the big face.
You know you're tied to them. You don't
really want to bring them down, because
it's like--oh my god, I'm tied to them--
and we're both going down. This is what was
happening 02008. So there needs to
be another part of the plan in place. Which
simply is a government that understands
that at that point the basket for saving
the finance climber that you have
suddenly clipped their belay and they're
falling--the basket is this:
you nationalize them. We nationalized GM in
02008. It worked. They paid us back.
We saved their ass. The real economy needed
saving. Finance we paid off. We bailed out
at 100 cents on the dollar to the tune
of somewhere between $7 trillion and
$13 trillion. I've heard both figures
Friday at UCI I heard $13 trillion by
a very distinguished economic historian.
This is because of quantitative easing,
as well as the original bailout. So
that amount of money is kind of amazing.
But this time if we've crashed the bank
or if they happen to blow a bubble
on their own... either way we have to
at that point say "Yes we'll bail you out. But
now we own you ." And so now we own you
means the government is the Board of Directors.
That we begin to set regulations. We begin
to determine loans. It would be like
the federal credit union. All of these things
have their precedence in earlier Public
Utility District type moves. So
at that point with the government taking over
it would run the loan strategies,
the repayment rates... and to
the extent that it profited the profits
would just go into the Treasury. You
combine that with the obvious carbon tax
that we need to put on... which is
not a tax but paying the true cost we need to
re-conceptualize. And then also the Thomas Piketty tax
which would be what he suggested 2 years ago,
which is you don't just have a progressive tax
on income--because people who are
wealthy enough can hide their income
in another country or under the rug or in
future... investments in the future.
So income you can hide.
Capital assets--a progressive tax,
sharply progressive tax
on capital assets is such a game changer,
such a paradigm buster, that when
The Wall Street Journal and The Economist
reviewed Piketty's book and they got to
this last chapter... they said "Oh, but
that would never work because..." and then
their 500 word article ran out. And
they got to stop at that point. They
never said why. Because there is no why.
Because it would work. And it would be an
incredibly powerful tool in terms of the
horizontalization of human wealth to
more of the population. There's hardly a
better suggestion. And Piketty's book may
have been, as some people said, you know...
11 chapters of Marxism followed by one
chapter of Keynesian reform suggestions.
But, you know, I'm a Keynesian myself.
I think we're in a Keynesian world. And I
think many people who do the 11 chapters
of Marxian analysis would then like to
contribute something useful that could
be done right now in the world. And a tax
structure is not the most
radical suggestion. It's already been done before.
So that would create a government surplus.
Instead of government being
in debt to finance forever in eternity,
and therefore under the thumb of finance,
government would (having a surplus)...
would be in control of finance and it
would have flipped the scissors-rock-
paper as to who controls who. At that
point, paper would...people would
control governments; governmental would control
finance; finance would work for the
people... you would have... the the way
the system needed to work. Now what would
we do with that money? Health care, of course.
Free public education, of course.
Through college? Why not? And then also
Full employment. Because full employment
is another gigantic paradigm buster for
Capitalism. We have 5.4%
5.4% minimum unemployment. If it goes
below that the market's depressed. And
you want Labor wage pressure. Wage pressure
is pressure on human beings lives and
minds in order to keep them willing to
work for depressed wages--so that profits
will be better. Once again it's going
back to that one algorithm. So what
you would want at that point with
full employment, if you could always get
a good living wage job from the government,
then private industries that existed...
which would be on the margin I would
call it... would have to compete by giving
a living wage themselves. And everybody
would have one
along with Social Security. So what would
everybody do?
This idea that automation is going to get rid of
jobs is a very silly, bad science fiction story.
It's not right. It's not going to
be that way. Many things take the human
touch. Taking care of young people. Taking
care of old people. Taking care of sick
people. And also "landscape restoration".
That's the environmental work of this
project. Of government that's in
control of the human / biosphere future,
because the two are tied together. It
would be an enormous amount of infrastructure
changes and landscape restoration in
general to get us a planet where we're
not using up, you know, the biosphere's
regenerative possibilities by August of every year.
Which is what we're doing now.
But are in balance with the biosphere properly.